hello everyone i'm alan welcome to my
channel um where
he's a dog nose
it's just right there oh
i'm fostering a dog she likes a lot of
attention so you may hear her throughout
the course of this video we're catching
up on the nintendo direct um
they've basically always happened during
my work hours so i always have to watch
um
later
and uh i managed to completely avoid
spoilers i have no idea what's in this i
just went off social media um while the
director was happening and in the
various like friend group text threads
that exist where they were talking about
it i just stopped reading um
i would love to see more of that kirby
game
hopeful for
zelda even though i feel like that's
very unlikely
um
those are my main requests really so
let's uh again apologies about the dog
i'm not going to kick her out of the
room she's still in a very anxious stage
because she's just come out of being in
a shelter for a very long time i'm sure
she'll be eating bones and whatever back
there but um let's do it let's watch it
beautiful
it's not zelda i thought it was zelda
fireball
cool
yeah i uh
recognize the cycle of this world i will
not allow it to perish with you
[Music]
this is the path we must walk
i have ambitions edelgard real ones
honestly
i feel like makes me good for a very
long time for a miracle
or will you help me seize control of my
but the most recent installments
absolute banks
we shall fight
we shall survive and we shall win a
glorious future for foodland
hell yeah
[Music]
cool revenge is not a thing you take for
someone else
[Music]
you seek revenge to slake your rage and
heal your wounded you can't tell me
that's not molgana i i would not believe
you are prepared to do whatever that you
must
that's very soon
looks good
hello everyone
i'm sheena takahashi and i'll be your
guide for today's nintendo direct
[Music]
what you just saw was the trailer for
the fire emblem warriors three hopes
game
[Music]
you'll look forward to a different story
set in the same universe as fire emblem
three houses no
three houses let's see the first batch
of nintendo switch headlines
thank you i love nintendo direct so much
orange star nation needs you
[Music]
we've got more intel on the advance wars
oneplus 2 reap boot camp game
in the first campaign advance wars
you'll play in advance
of commanding but i have some friends
who really love their abilities in
vibrant turn-based battles each
commanding officer is now voiced
bringing even more charm to these
characters you're gonna get hurt i see
right through your plans another full
campaign awaits in advance wars 2 black
hole rising more commanding officers and
more animation styles leveraged for
additional tactical opportunities i
don't know how our fans feel about
pipelines to cross into enemy territory
in both campaigns you can fast-forward
game progress in the event
for a smoother tactical experience
flex your strategic muscles outside of
both campaigns with additional modes
go for high scores in the war room
create and share custom maps in the
design room
or battle friends and frenemies in local
and online multiplayer
[Music]
advance wars one plus two reboot i mean
yeah they listen on to the nintendo
switch
i could be convinced
but based on how they look i'm like
not really into it and that's okay you
never know all of the infinite universe
in no man's sky
i thought that was is the light that
looks like no man's sky
did we know this already
each orbited by planets
it's such a good game i spend all your
time in that's most of my relationships
i don't know if everyone's like that in
the authorities
your journey may be fraught with danger
and actions have consequences traitor
also for the record i'm muting
my mic just for the sake of explorer
how will you live in this universe
no man's sky lands on nintendo switch
this summer that's awesome hell yes
oh i recognize all of you hello my
friends
only gamers know who mario is you know
what i'm saying only only real gamers
know who mario is
only real gamers
recognize bowser
he's a real gamer hours what is this
[Music]
thoughts really cool
[Music]
mario striker's battle league all right
prepare for strife hell yeah i'll play
five sport like soccer that's way
different
aim for goals by dribbling and hell yeah
dude this could be super fun
using tackles
items
and crushing special shots
the main rule in this sport is to rule
the field
try to score more goals than your
opponents i'm so down for this
competitive multiplayer chaos with
friends
first the gear you equip it changes not
only your appearance but also your stats
like speed strength and pass accuracy
customize as you see fit
second
the hyper strike
to activate this shot grab an orb when
it appears on the field
and charge it while your opponents are
distracted
hit the nothing left you'll score not
one but two goals guys
individual matches
online play will have an online club
mode
join an in-game club and compete for
placement in the rankings
up to 20 players can join a club so
create your own and invite friends and
family to play alongside you or join an
existing one owned by other players
try to become the world's tough club
hell yeah i'm so down for this
tackles
you also don't need to show me small
like this is enough
mario
launches on nintendo switch june 10.
also again it begins
all the time now that i don't work in
media and i actually work in games the
latest iteration of the mario strikers
we hope you're excited for this anything
goes battle soccer game
hell yeah
this looks recognizable but i don't
think it went away
oh
it's bloody boys
never got into splatoon either even
though i know it's good
[Music]
[Music]
they also do like a very good job of
marketing splatoon i think
like i've played it
just not into it in a way that i know a
lot of people are um
but i feel like the trailers are always
really fun and i love all the events
[Music]
let's do a good job keeping that
community alive
but wait this isn't used
[Music]
wait wasn't three already
[Music]
that's cool
i haven't seen that before
that looks neat
[Music]
i'm guessing
[Music]
run next wave cool
that was the trailer for the co-op mode
in the splatoon 3
the next wave of salmon run
a giant salmonid one that's never been
seen before was also spotted at the end
of the trailer will the inklings and
octolings
come out or swim
splatoon
there you go you'll look forward to
future that's cool yeah
i don't know if they're still actually
pleased with more nintendo switch
headlines
nate loved love to see splatoon gameplay
[Music]
can you imagine if this is having a full
room of the first front mission game is
storming onto nintendo switch still sick
but can you imagine
in this tactical rpg you'll pilot
weaponized machines called vonsers and
lead your battalion to victory said
bonzo that makes sense
yeah i mean i always look at the upper
hand and back but can you imagine if it
was macarena
that will be wild
mix and match various weapons and parts
to customize your bronzer
uncover the great storyline this classic
when front mission 1
this summer sucks to be there and in the
future the sequel front mission 2 remake
will also launch on nintendo switch
get set for a high octane disney and
pixar combat racer
from the crew
special abilities
sully for monstrous power or mulan for
explosive maneuvers
each racer also possesses powerful
ultimate skills perfect for turning the
tables at the last second
disney speedstorm is a free-to-play game
with new seasons added regularly
bringing more exciting disney and pixar
characters that's interesting
carts and more
plus enjoy cross-platform play as well
as split screen and online multiplayer
modes that's cool
disney speed storm run out onto nintendo
switch this summer
cool
[Music]
dive into these classic franchises on
nintendo switch
unleash the power of the force in this
classic star wars action adventure as
darth vader's secret apprentice
predictable but good dating force nice
and lightsaber combos unleash down jedi
masters on iconic planets
upgrade abilities like force grip and
force repulse then combine them for even
more destructive combos
use button controls or opt for motion
controls enhanced from the original wii
version
you can also dual locally with a friend
to determine who is the galaxy's most
powerful jedi
star wars the force unleashed launches
on nintendo's i mean i i'm such a fan of
like letters today on nintendo
and 16th century constantine i don't
feel like the original
including touch screen controls hd
rumble and optimized on-screen display
assassin's creed the ezio collection
launches a nintendo switch february 17th
i yeah i don't know if they haven't
mobile shoots in dynamic action rpg
battles nice strange incidents called
breaks are occurring across the gundam
universe find out what's causing them
[Music]
two worlds cross in the triumphant
return of this rpg classic
a remaster of the acclaimed rpg chrono
cross is coming to the nintendo switch
system chrono trigger and protocol one
fateful day the protagonists
[Music]
he finds that he no longer exists that's
neat how did this happen
what is this mysterious another world
travel back and forth between both
worlds to unravel the story
over 40 characters can join your party
depending on the choices you make the
allies who accompany you and the endings
that trigger will differ that's a lot of
characters a number of improvements have
been made to this remaster damn like the
ability to turn off enemy encounters
and a newly enhanced soundtrack
what does that mean plus radical dreams
what does that mean originally released
on the satellite enemy encounters does
that mean like you've been told
in this text-based adventure
chrono cross the radical dreamers
edition dashes and slashes its way onto
nintendo switch april 7th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop
[Music]
i am down i am especially down for this
i'm so excited about this game
i like cannot even begin to explain how
excited i am about the new kobe
[Music]
3d kobe oh oh you're going to eat them
you're going to eat them are you going
to do it little cub
you've got my little windmill you oh
[Music]
there's a kink about that
oh
my god
you didn't transform in him you just ate
it
oh you just you just had him where you
like the latest unforgettable 3d
platforming adventure kirby and the
forgotten land i can't wait i can't
believe how much i am about
with an unusual mix of nature and
civilization
to rescue the kidnapped waddle dees
kirby sets off on a new adventure
[Applause]
[Music]
you kind of look like a waddledee
introducing
[Music]
a vending machine to attack with juice
cans
oh my god
or become a piercing cone
it keeps getting better how do they keep
improving on the thing mouthful mode new
actions will be available
depending on the object he inhales oh my
god gosh
enjoy may kirby live forever different
from okay make cubby long makeup yeah
can even weaponize a mouthful of water
like this you just throw yourself at
somebody
kirby rescues waddle deep
will continue to grow and yeah sources
will become available
there's no way this game lives up to the
hype i have in my head but i don't doubt
that i will find it funny
familiar copy abilities can be evolved
[Music]
evolve copy abilities to expand kirby's
range of attacks
they'll also change kirby's appearance
and make him even more powerful
[Music]
some copy abilities may have stronger
involved forms
[Music]
dragon new adventure awaits our pink
puffball
[Music]
who were the beast
what are these enemies trying to do
[Music]
can kirby restore peace to this world
kirby and the forgotten land launches on
the nintendo switch
on the systems eshop
i can't wait
that was kirby and the forgotten land
launching later next month
please look forward to its release
let's take a look at some more nintendo
switch headlines
[Applause]
m
mlb the show is coming to nintendo
switch i know people really like these
games you can play modes like road to
the show and diamond dynasty on your
nintendo switch but that's not all you
can even play exhibition with a single
joy-con switch thing with cross
progression you can also earn and use
content on any platform where mlb the
show 22 is available and take your
progress on the goal with you on
nintendo switch have friends that play
mlb the show 22 online matches on other
consoles
no need to worry you can advise you
don't need to worry about it
you'll be fine
launches on april 5th
i knew you were a true two-way player
but this is ridiculous
sheesh hmm they're joycon choices there
you're gonna have your hands full of
games with these collections
three kingdom hearts collections are
almost here yeah do it for the culture
kingdom hearts to kingdom hearts three
and the remind
[Music]
and more for the first time in tv
tabletop or handheld mode
cool kingdom hearts intragram
masterpiece for cloud containing all
three game collections soars onto
nintendo switch tomorrow i don't think
that oh
each collection's cloud version will
also be individually available on
nintendo eshop
clinoa is coming to nintendo switch
across dreamy side-scrolling levels
you'll run jump and hover while firing
wind bullets to grab and throw enemies
use each level surroundings to your
advantage
[Music]
also clinoa 2 is included
take on these great adventures when
clinoa fantasy reverie series launches a
nintendo switch july 8th
we're so glad you're here that's a good
video game you come here
i think portal
you're in for a puzzling treat
in these awards
the portal gun is your key to surviving
imprisonment in a mysterious world
create portals and warped to other areas
to find
cake
still unconfirmed you can pass through
portals and so can cubes please
come on
levels of personality come on
the sequel adds in local
companion collection warps onto nintendo
switch this year always love portal
always love portals i'll play that on
planes let's go classic comes alive
[Music]
very exciting i'm sure that i know a lot
of people who are going to be losing
their minds over this one when i go on
the toilet timeline
hell yeah dude
i bet you i have a million friends
outside of japan the rpg
to be able to play debut now in hd 2d
stories featuring different protagonists
and time periods await that's awesome
but you tackle them is up to you
pre-history a tribesman comes of age
undertakes an important secret mission
it looks good present day a martial
artist strives to become the strongest
there ever was
the near future a youth with psychic
powers takes a stand against evil the
distant future a newly built robot is
swept up in a tragedy in space what
other stories are on the horizon i don't
think if i know correctly
i think the game has ever been in death
properly released in english right
launches on nintendo switch july 22nd
that's huge oh man there are so many
people that i want to talk to about that
one
damn
i'm assuming
next up is this
next up is this
it's a new iteration of the wii sports
oh my god
the game of switch sports it's back
please take a look oh my god my mom's
finally gonna get a switch
here are the sports included in the
nintendo switch sports game bowling all
the classics recognize yes three from
past weeks yes let's go
again only real games rally by gently
swinging the joy-con controller at the
right time
[Music]
bring it back
i'm so ready straight ahead or give it a
little curve
and chambra
knock your opponent off the platform
while attacking and defending
all right
plus three additional sports are joining
the lineup how do you play volleyball
soccer
use a gigantic ball to make dynamic
plays what a lot of soccer games huh
enjoy
[Music]
by attaching a joy-con controller to the
leg strap accessory included with the
physical version of the game you can
play shootout mode with intuitive
kicking motions
that seems dangerous badminton
control your shots left and right just
keep going
in the air
unleash powerful smash shots to gain the
upper hand
[Music]
finally volleyball
use a joy-con controller to serve
it was volleyball
i'm just i played volleyball
in high school spike the ball you gotta
jump you gotta you gotta jump in
volleyball that's going to be really
weird to play and not be allowed to do
game supports local play with family and
friends on one nintendo switch system
as well as online play across all
families gonna come visit
[Music]
play against friends online
or opt for random magazines it's a remix
of the song the more you get my branding
tougher the players you'll see but it's
not quite the same it just starts out
the same
try taking on this challenge
what a banger what a banger how was that
since i'm already here i'd like to show
you some gameplay of one of the newly
added sports volleyball
okay mr takahashi
oh
hello there everyone i'm yoshiaki
koizumi from nintendo wow mr koizumi i
can see you're ready to play
all right i'll play some volleyball
online together with mr koizumi do you
have your wrist strap ready
yes of course
i've got plenty of space around me as
well amazing just gotta make sure gotta
make sure thanks nintendo appreciate
that all right let's start
we'll be including some live commentary
throughout our match
all right oh we're doing this uh
volleyball a newly added sport in
nintendo switch sports
what can we expect today from the
takahashi koizumi team
it's koizumi to serve with takahashi up
front
god we begin with koizumi no just how
will the opposing team oh my god the way
they do this takahashi makes the block
another one's coming i just don't feel
like anybody else could do this you know
set up in the air and here comes the
spike
the other team saves it and fights bad
and they score takahashi didn't quite
get it in time
all right well it's okay it's okay the
game's not over
now the other team serves
koizumi receives it takahashi sets it up
and koizubi spikes but it goes right
toward the opponent
here's another attack
now's their chance
they're gonna come out losing and with
the setup from kuazumi takahashi scores
there we go nice score mate got a point
with that fierce spike
whoa i believe that was genuine
after all we were in the middle of a
presentation
all right i'll be leaving now
that was an introduction to nintendo
switch sports
the game launches april 29th
we're planning a free update in the
summer that allows you to play soccer
matches with a joy-con controller and
the leg strap accessory you can use the
accessory to play shootout mode at
launch
in addition
we're also planning a second free update
this fall that lets you enjoy golf
[Music]
and now a request to everyone
to help ensure that you can all enjoy
playing online we'll be having an online
play test before the game launches to
evaluate various technical aspects
[Music]
we definitely like to ask for your help
with this also you have to pay for it
available
online membership on the date you can't
play alongside friends for those of you
interested please visit the official
nintendo website you can give it a try i
could like stream it or something that's
really soon thank you
it's next week
man i do also love that's all i have for
now about nintendo switch sports oh i
hope you're looking forward to this game
let's see a few more nintendo switch
headings okay thank you i do love how
quickly they announce and then release
things huge fan of that
[Music]
get those
skills ready the game that i played in
the arcade in japan
it is the latest taikono toxigen game is
coming to the nintendo switch system set
in omiko city the sacred town for taiko
drums you'll strive to become a taiko
master along with brand new character
kumokun
drum to dozens of popping beats
including megalovania gurenge it's a
little bit creepy
and racing into that's a little bit
crazy
these games are really fun an orchestral
version of the main theme
take advantage of a practice mode to
replace sections of songs as many times
as you'd like
new modes have also been added for
everyone to enjoy put on a live
[Music]
drum to your heart's content
when taiko no tatsujin rhythm festival
launches on nintendo switch this year
plus a paid in-game subscription service
that gives you access to over 500 songs
will be available at launch can you have
them anyway
[Music]
what's new with these nintendo switch
games yeah we got some updates
the brand new tactical rpg game triangle
strategy is almost here
the protagonist sarah noah and his
allies will be engulfed in the conflict
among three nations your choices and
conviction will determine their fate as
lord of house wolford i solemnly swear
an oath by which all future lords shall
be bound i will never turn my back on
the promise of a better world
a new demo playable to the end of
chapter 3 will be available on nintendo
eshop later today
save data from the demo can be
transferred to the full game once
purchased
more cuphead action awaits in the paid
dlc really excited about the delicious
last course
here you'll explore cuphead
a bevy of new again with wild
personalities and even wilder attacks
just because i'm hyped about it the
clever miss chalice is a new playable
character
take down fearsome foes with her double
jumps rolling dodges and more
cuphead the delicious last course
wallops attorney great idea nintendo
switched june 30.
[Music]
a free update is coming to the metroid
dread game
all it takes is one good update
that's it i'm still not finished
getting hit even once causes a game over
in the brutal dread mode difficult oh my
god
oh my gosh new challenge
players new to the metro matches
take advantage of increased recovery
with the newly added rookie mode
difficulty
yeah that's what people are used to
that's a great idea later today what a
good idea to what
a second free update in april will add a
boss rush mode in which you'll battle
bosses continuously that sounds a lot of
time
yeah i really really do like metric
threat i just didn't i didn't finish it
too many video games you know what i'm
saying something's bound for nintendo
switch
they did it
[Applause]
no
oh my god
you love to see it you love to see it
holy crap that's gonna be the highlight
of this for me
[Music]
can you believe it
oh my gosh
i there's no way that i don't know a
bunch of people who are stupid excited
about this one as well
it's so nice to have a bunch of friends
during the game so i'd be like i know
that you're gonna care about live a lot
i'm gonna text you about that the same
as i found
[Music]
that's rad
how cool
[Music]
you look stupid
video games she's come so far
just come so far oh hello yeah i know
you won that
i'm not paying attention
40 whole minutes i'm the devil
[Music]
hell yeah
earthbound and earthbound beginnings
that's so right
online later today what also today
they can't keep doing this they can't
keep getting away with this
oh my gosh what an event
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a whole zombie shock oh my god
i i intend to check the game out
actually
i also didn't know it came out today i
might do um gameplay it looks beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
i did think the art style of two point
campus looks really neat
[Music]
what did you think
here's some news from mario kart fans
many of you have been enjoying the mario
kart 8 deluxe games since he's launched
ever released a new one
we've been working on remastering select
courses from across the mario kart
series that makes a lot of people
releasing
downloadable content
please take a look at this training on
that monetization strategy man they're
doing it they're out here doing it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
paid dlc courses will be coming to mario
kart 8 deluxe
this is the mario kart 8 deluxe booster
course pass
you may recognize some courses from past
mario kart games
eight courses will be released at a time
over six waves
that's 48 additional courses we plan on
releasing wow at the end of 2023
that's actually nuts coconut milk hello
i'm sorry i'm all my enthusiasm
oh yes choco mountain let's go
tokyo blur
included in the first wave damn that's
so much content dude you can play these
courses
and online
[Music]
march 18th
pre-orders begin today a nintendo eshop
i'm all right you can enjoy this dlc at
no additional cost with a nintendo
switch online plus expansion pack
membership or purchase the mario kart 8
deluxe booster course pass on its own
[Music]
how was that great thank you i hope
you're looking forward to the additional
courses in mario kart 8 deluxe that's
actually sick this next segment will be
our last announcement
please take a look what is it
what is it
[Music]
fighting in order to live
and living to fight
is that how you play a flute
that's the way of our world that looks
wrong to me
oh my gosh
hello big boy tell me
what would possess you to side with them
we're fighting because there are enemies
to kill everybody's friends to believe
you're him everybody's always brilliant
i saw this coming you are you're not
enemies now fine for you isn't it all
that time you've got you could try try
to move forwards again
it's the only way you're gonna defeat
the real enemy this voice acting is
killing me but
whatever life is lost i won't let you
soldier all alone what could filling up
these flickering clocks in our eyes it
will never replace the predatory rock
the flame it has to go
uroboros are bore this world they must
be erased without a trace
okay
okay hi
the vistas look beautiful
that's gorgeous also the combat looks
really cool
[Music]
it makes sense to me that that unused
blade is is a what that is and b is the
thing they would end with never played
one
that looks cool though
i'm into it
love to see all the 20 20 releases i
think you need to go to the bathroom huh
the story of xenoblade chronicles 3 ties
together the futures of the worlds
depicted in xenoblade chronicles and
xenoblade chronicles 2 and it will
launch this september nice i hope you
look forward to it
that's all for today's nintendo direct
thank you for watching what happened to
him
are they lying nah that is it okay
um i love the way they pace them they're
always fun to watch even like when there
are games that i'm not interested in i
don't feel like they ever overstay their
welcome or anything
um i have to take the dog to the
bathroom
thank you all for joining me i'll see
you guys next time